it's woke
Wednesday right yeah 60c puff pastry did
you see that video of the woman who said
the airlines with their cramped spaces
are discriminating against fat people
people tell me every day that I
shouldn't be allowed on a plane because
of my size I'm here to remind you your
size doesn't have to hold you
back she's right everyone is arguing
with her and I can't believe how badly
fat phobia has cucked you all a woman is
arguing for more space on airplanes than
you're saying no that's
right you're Pro Airline now because you
hate fat people that much what is wrong
with yeah I know fat people aren't a
protected class but thinking fatness is
just a choice is stupid and you're
stupid for thinking it very few fat
people want to be fat and fatness is
mostly caused by genetics and the food
industry yeah not providing
accommodations and essentially public
spaces for people's physical limitations
can be
discriminatory but all that aside the
airlines treat you like the airlines
hate you they hate you almost as much as
you hate fat people so yeah we need more
space than airplanes and remember fat
people are human beings Airline
executives are not yummy uh he makes
some points and I like the the puff
thing the part that he's right about is
that the airlines take a lot of stuff
away from us that's true now in part
this has been to control the growth of
costs and I don't know I actually still
like a lot of airlines even though they
squeeze us and they shrink the seats and
then do all sorts of stuff if everyone
were to have a bigger seat the costs
would go up for everybody so that's
that's why people who don't need three
seats would object to this sort of
accommodation what he's wrong about is
that fatness is not a choice he's half
right and that a lot of people can't
control themselves and they have all
sorts of problems and we all have sins
and vices that we fall into and for some
people it's gluttony and that's true but
no one is Big boned there's shoddy
evidence even that thyroid conditions
and things like that are responsible for
obesity uh there are some factors from
you know how one is acculturated how one
is raised the kind of food that one eats
absolutely that's that's a big part of
it uh the uh self-control that one gains
or does not gain yeah that's true and
also because freedom is really just the
ability to will something and the
ability to will something is contingent
upon the ability to know something then
if you have not disciplined yourself if
you've not been properly raised or
educated and if you have some ignorance
then you're not going to have a perfect
freedom and so you might say well I
wasn't perfectly free to to be fat or
thin or something okay yeah I guess
that's all true I don't know that he's
really going as deep there uh but it's
no excuse and it's not helpful to people
to to just encourage them in things that
are harmful to them suicide is bad ass
so while there might be some exceptions
to be made for people who are on certain
medications or for whatever reason are
not able to fit in the seat or sure we
try to make all sorts of exceptions and
accommodations for people
as a as a broader rule no I don't think
we need to make all Airline seats three
times bigger just because Americans are
getting fatter that that's not going to
solve the problem that's going to
encourage the problem it's going to make
us less healthy and less happy and less
able to flourish I traveled the banks of
the river of
Jordan to find where it flows to the
Sea